big thanks to Lisa mihalick because we
are late to this video because of the
fact that our camera stopped working it
was a really nice surprise when
comic-con rolls around and at the last
minute at least let us borrow her camera
so thank you my dear really appreciate
that what's going on reject nation it's
Greg Alba here John we're going to be
watching the trailer for Titans this is
going on the DC streaming a service
people DCSS I don't really know the
Titans all that well man I'm not gonna
try to BS you guys into thinking I do I
really do like a lot of those like CW DC
shows and this is on a separate thing
it's probably not even connected our
patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions over there I cover the flash
literally watch the last two episodes of
season 4 last night
I also cover attack on Titan just
started Gotham John covers Riverdale
Atlanta Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
together we cover my hero academia
Jessica Jones season 2 Black Lightning
one more episode to go Cobra Kai people
and who knows maybe we'll add this on to
list when it comes out anyway let's
watch this okay
mm no it's not so I guess that you can
controller
[Music]
sometimes when I feel the darkness you
feel
[Music]
I used to think that
well certainly pulpy looking certainly
bloody it kind of does look like one of
the best fan film trailers got a lot of
their friends together yeah
cool fan feel yeah that really knows his
after-effects yeah I think there's a lot
of cool visual stuff to behold here cuts
back and forth thing like this greyish a
bluish dark tint to throughout it really
feels insanely dark I kind of like that
what's cool about this is it's a
live-action DC show you know I haven't
seen the Krypton show or whatever
looking at all the CW shows this looks
and feels very different what I find
kind of humorous about it it's wanting
to be this really serious DC show it's
lighting looks like it a lot of its
violence looks like that too there's
some dialogue still like that cheesy
dialogue that I personally really enjoy
yeah love that cheese I just don't know
if it'll mesh well with this because
Black Lightning is a dark show but it's
not cheesy and the way the other ones
have been this feels darker than black
lightning but still has the cheesy
dialogue yeah this trailer for me kind
of fell halfway between what I've seen
of a number of the CW shows and then
just like heaping on piles of darkness
on top of that and so it made me wonder
what the finished product would
ultimately look like because this is
kind of like in-between what my
expectations were
which leaves potential like it could be
cool and I'm certainly intrigued by the
fact that they're starting their own
authored universe over here with its own
aesthetic I'm kind of wondering like
what their budget is and and you know
where they're gonna go with this stuff
but I can see the potential in it but
I'm not as like out-of-the-park sold on
this trailer as I wanted to be I guess I
think Raven looks really cool and that's
actually that's actually a character
I've kind of wanted to see come to
in the modern way so in that way like
I'm kind of excited for that
Starfire looks kind of cool you know
these are characters that some of them
are a little bit of it maybe at all
orders but she's like Starfire might be
a tall order for TV but I feel like the
action looks really cool and Robin looks
really cool it could be really cheesy to
pull up in a darker world in but seeing
him fighting everything I'm excited for
that and maybe they're gonna transition
him into being Nightwing which would
make me a very happy camper he really
reminds me of Grant Gustin Singh an
Andrew Garfield yeah if you crash them
together it reminds me of the both of
them so you know a trailer is not enough
time for him to become distinct in my
mind but I liked the the Robin stuff
especially when you have that wide shot
in the alleyway where he just swoops
over the top really quick those things
make me feel like this could be
something really cool and unique but
some of the other elements make me feel
like it could just feel like a beefed up
CW show if you're gonna do dark and
gritty it's more than just its visual
flair it's more than just the violence
and a few f-bombs here or there you
really need to have a good script ooh
yes it is who seems so on the nose this
is something about the tone didn't a
hundred percent coalesced for this I'm
not a I'm not even exactly worried about
that because I feel like most of the DC
hairs are and even for a lot of the
Marvel shows as well they don't seem to
have trailers that like for the TV shows
that really represent the show totally
confused yeah because they're not so
much a span that they kind of make this
like super cut of a season that I'm not
even really concerned about I'm like I
just gotta wait to find out for the show
but when you're hearing dialogue those
really cringe-worthy that line when she
says sometimes when I feel like this Oh
insane Legionnaire I'm sure I've heard
that line before
from a number of people in your exact
position look if I'm being honest it
feels a little pretentious we're doing
the dark version of it you can feel them
saying that although I think it totally
has the potential to absolutely find its
footing maybe even from the pilot I
think shows like arrow and Gotham even
start off a little bit funky you and
they're really dark DC shows but they
eventually find their footing and I
think they get really good
and I think Titans can totally have that
capability I think for movies you can
say you can't really judge movie based
on the trailer sure I feel like it's
easier to predict what a movies gonna be
bad or good huh movie trailer well
you've got maybe a two-hour three-hour
PM of clips and most as opposed to like
12 ya know it's very much hardening a
trailer for ya how do you properly
represent everything in a neat package
without having to pull a couple really
blunt lines of dialogue right now I'm
really 50/50 on this and I feel like I
want this to be good more than I think
it's gonna be alright guys well did you
see the timing's trailer you excited for
it - is your favorite I did you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell check us on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s music video coverage would
love to have you become a patron eject
to die